uh the arden bomb shelter was created
and we don't know or i don't know the
exact year that it was created but it
was created to be
the headquarters
for all the bomb shelters in the vegas
valley and
for
the in in case of
an attack you know if the bomb shelter
system had to be activated
the
uh mayors the
county commission
uh the sheriff
the
police chiefs the
fire chiefs all of that would have
gathered at the arden bomb shelter
and they would have coordinated
um all the the efforts uh from that site
it was set up to handle
27 men and nine women
i'm not saying anything about the
equality there um
but that was set up to be it was it was
far enough away
in the 1950s
from where they thought the
bombs
would have hit
that it would have survived and it would
have been in touch with all of the other
bomb shelters in the valley and there
were quite a few of them every one of
the properties had a basement room that
was set up to be
a bomb shelter it was stocked in other
words
the
flamingo underpass the charleston
underpass both had bomb shelters set up
um there were
basically every abandoned mine that they
could they stocked with
non-perishable foods um so it was
that there was
areas set up all over the valley for
people to be able to get to and
hopefully
survive um for those of us that remember
those days um but there had to be
somewhere that was
the headquarters where everybody would
gather who was in charge and would be
able to then
coordinate
what was going on on up on the surface
well arden was where there was a cement
plant out there it was
a
mined uh uh gypsum out there but it was
miles away it was
quite a ways out it was a junction point
on the union pacific in fact that's
where they had decided was the closest
point that they could connect a railroad
to in order to bring supplies to the
hoover dam site
so that's where the the uh six companies
and the the railroad that went down to
the hoover dam site came off the
railroad out there
so it was quite a ways out
in in 19
well say the early 1950s
um we were probably somewhere around oh
i'm guessing here around 20 000 maybe
less than that
in the valley here so i figure we're
2.3 2.4 million at this point
20 000 at that point you're miles away
and and
they would have figured that
if
bombs were being dropped they would have
been dropped on
probably
nellis air force base it had changed to
nellis in 1950 so they would have aimed
at that
even if they had aimed at the airport
the airport was still very very little
so they probably wouldn't have been
worried about that you know they would
have aimed at
wherever there would have been some uh
possibility of
you know attacking back they wouldn't
have even aimed at the test site because
that was
literally only testing you you didn't
have nuclear weapons there they there
were nuclear weapons at mead view
out at lake mead which were
secretly there
and available then
to
nellis if they had to be
put on airplanes and
then
take off from nellis
but they would have aimed at nellis and
meadview not at
las vegas and
the little bit that henderson was at
that point henderson had only been
uh
incorporated in
1953 i think it was so you're not
talking about
a heavily populated area here this was a
very small area but the threat was
whether it was real or perceived it was
real
oh yeah but people felt the real threat
that they needed something like this
oh yes absolutely i mean i i was born in
1954 so i grew up
during this time when i was in grammar
school i had a bracelet that i wore that
had my name it had my address it had my
phone number it had my blood type on it
you know everything that was there in
case
you know there was a a
now i grew up in orange county
california um
but we did duck and cover drills just as
they were done here there were um
air raid sirens throughout the community
there's one of those that we saved and
restored out at the county museum you
can go out and actually see one of the
thunderers as the the type of air raid
siren it is but this was a very real
thing and and on both sides that that
sense that
could this happen absolutely
did anybody
really expect it to happen
i think
the interesting thing was i think among
us who were young
we lived with it and didn't really
expect it to happen
our parents
did they they had seen the bombs drop on
hiroshima
and nagasaki they they knew what that
was and and you know in the case of my
dad he was in training to go in on the
invasion on japan um he was in
underwater demolition in in the navy and
had done uh the invasions of iwo jima
and okinawa and so he knew what that
meant
um
but
when you grow up with it you just kind
of it's just part of the background of
growing up and so you just kind of
accept it
and the first time that i went into the
bomb shelter fallout shelter it's a real
place in
about 1990
seven 1996 somewhere back in there
um i hadn't been with the museums for
too long
at that point it was part of parks and
recreation
it was being leased from the
school district and being used by parks
and recreation they contacted the museum
and said
we've got a bomb shelter here with a
bunch of stuff in it would you like to
look at it
so i went with some of the other staff
and we looked at it and said yes we
would like to take selected artifacts so
that we can
you know
take these and and preserve them and and
have
enough pieces that we can talk about the
history of what this was and that's when
i got involved with the history of this
particular bomb shelter and started
doing some research on it and that
because my background is as an historian
i at the time was creating the aviation
museum at at the airport here
and um
we took a the the map that actually
showed all of the bomb shelter sites in
the valley here we took examples of the
uh radio equipment we took um
examples of the desks and chairs and
coveralls and all of that
what we left behind and what people see
in that video is actually not from
the time period of when it was a bomb
shelter
the the shelter was used in the
uh
80s and
throughout the 80s and even into the
late 80s
for
um exercises not for bomb shelter
exercises but for emergency exercises
the national guard used it and that sort
of thing so
that material is much later and so we
didn't need that it was not
it didn't reference
the period of time that the shelter was
built for so we didn't take that and and
it it just wasn't uh apropos to the
story that we wanted to document in the
history of that site so there's uh you
know they they had
a lot of uniforms left behind and that
sort of thing and they were
they weren't uniforms with any
particular insignia or anything they
were just dungarees and and you know
coveralls that sort of thing and and
there was some foodstuffs left behind
they weren't in any shape that you would
want to see
there were some some cans we took
example cans
but we didn't take all of them because
you only need one or two you don't need
15 of them you know it's it's something
where when you're
documenting a site you don't have to
empty the site to document it so the
other ones we just left there because
they weren't necessary for
documenting that site
the
difficulty with that site is that it's
an extremely toxic site
it's
the the site itself what they did when
they built that and it was typical of
the time
but they dug a big hole they used
railroad ties which were soaked with
creosote
at at that point in time i've worked
with creosote in my life when before i
was ever in the museum field um creosote
is a wonderful material if you don't
want bugs you know eating your railroad
ties
but they don't eat your railroad ties
because it's highly toxic and
carcinogenic
so
you know you can go down there and you
smell the creosote
then they were painted with lead-based
paint
so not only do you have a carcinogen
that you're breathing in you also have
this this the the standard really ugly
green lead-based paint on it
so
it
while
there is a a sort of sense that it would
be wonderful to be able to show people
that and walk through it
it would be very difficult to make it
safe for people to do it
to make it
ada accessible would be nearly
impossible because it was not built to
be
ada accessible literally you go down a
straight staircase you hit the bottom
there's a shower head over your head
you're supposed to strip down when you
get there and get showered off you walk
down a little alley the little corridor
very narrow too narrow for ada
not only the fact that you're going down
steps
and then you
put on these coveralls that are right
there in just a cubby and then you go
around the corner and you're in this
enclosed space
where if you were down there with 36
other people
within a week or two
you'd probably be heading back up on the
surface you know if if you have any
claustrophobia i i do you know i'd be
heading up you know it's one of those
that it would be very hard
to spend a long period of time down
there
plus the fact that if you did
you're setting yourself up for cancer in
the future and a lot of other problems
um
and trying to make this available to the
public you know because i've worked with
a lot of historic structures
yeah
i'm not sure how you'd be able to do
that you know there there are
interesting historic sites i would
almost rather take one of the
abandoned mines
that are still out there with with
stocks of food in them
and say
this is the kind of thing that we did
this is how we were trying
to deal with
you know the idea of bombing